Gwen Stefani is thankful for love while
I'm thankful for pink and Channing
Tatum's new colorful collaboration Plus
have a sneak peak of a GT champ
Darcy land on pentatonix Christmas
special hello friends I'm Denny direct
oh and this is you guessed it the daily
Denny the countdown is on until I'm
faced deep at a plate of turkey and
mashed potatoes that's right
Thanksgiving is just a couple of days
away you guys and miss Gwen Stefani who
has a new holiday record out will be
spreading some Christmas joy at this
year's Thanksgiving Day Parade on NBC he
just caught up with her in New York City
as she prepares for Thursday's festive
gig oh this is just magical I mean it's
just crazy when you to be part of
tradition you know mean and it's a
little overwhelming when I walked out
here and I saw the stage I lost my
breath I was like and these buildings in
this New York and it's cold and it's
white oh it's just been so fun
Gwen says she has plenty to be thankful
for this year she will spend
Thanksgiving in Oklahoma with her
sexiest man alive beau Blake Shelton
after the parade in New York and she let
us in on one of her favorite Turkey Day
traditions oh yeah so in my family we go
big with tradition that's the bodies we
not go and
one where we go around and everybody
takes a letter of Thanksgiving my pH and
you make up whatever you're grateful for
and you pass a candle around so
everybody gets really creative and it's
really sweet to hear the kids like try
to figure it out
gosh I have so many things to be
thankful for but I would have to say I
would just be so grateful and thankful
for the love that I have all around me
right now I'm so I'm so full of love you
guys Blake and Gwen are so cute on each
other these days we all agree they're
moving up for like a nine on the John
and Chrissy scale let me say yeah all
right you know who else is feeling the
love pink fresh off her high rise am a
performance she's raising the bar again
with Magic Mike that's right Channing
Tatum plays Pink's main man in this
retro video for beautiful trauma but the
two are not your typical fifties
housewife and husband
[Music]
guess who's gonna have to die to remind
us that it feels like we chose this
[Music]
some days like a bail you breathing
[Music]
you know you just can't unsee chanting
in a dress he look so comfortable in one
all right you know we have mrs. Magic
Mike Jenna Dewan Tatum to thank for
making this collaboration come together
she was Pink's backup dancers now
speaking of the dancing the same
choreographers behind that am a stunt
and her video for try put this one
together and during the credits you can
see Channing and pink just having a
blast behind the scenes oh we have the
full video up for you guys up at et
online.com but right now it's time to
check back in with one of my old pals
America's Got Talent season 12 winner
Darcy Lynn farmer we had to first look
at her performance for a very pentatonix
Christmas special et's Kevin Frazier was
there behind the scenes what woke
between you do with you what really come
on no it's between you're ready to sing
yeah with pentatonix no way
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do you have a favorite Christmas
tradition with your family on Christmas
Eve from my parents really all right so
what are you gonna get petunia this year
petunia what are you gonna get Darci
Lynne and petunia will rock the stage
during a very pentatonic Christmas which
airs Monday on NBC Jennifer Hudson also
joined the acapella group for this
special and we'll have that sneak peek
for you guys tomorrow so until then you
know the drill like and comment this
video and ring the bell
I'll be back tomorrow with more video
one more video before the holiday
[Music]